all right Angel how long has it been
since you were here last I believe it
was like a year ago now it's been at
least a year yeah and I interviewed your
girlfriend recently yeah um Jada Jada
yeah she uh she had an interesting story
yeah she's that's one of the reasons why
we're together we both have quite a
story and almost yeah very similar
backgrounds yeah foster care all that
stuff you know home to home yeah what
happened to your face um well some dude
was we were actually buying something
from a guy and um he had called her a
name and I felt like he disrespected her
and she's holding my child so I just
went off like I started to fight him and
then he kind of like threw me and like I
slid on the concrete stuff like that he
ended up hitting her too so kind of like
made me mad that I couldn't like defend
her at the moment but I stood up for her
so I guess that's what matters so she's
pregnant with your kid yeah how far
she's she's about two months now two
months you guys are going to keep it
yeah we're planning to you know I'm
trying to get her off to um stop smoking
you know it's hard because you know how
how do I tell an addict to stop smoking
and you know I'm an addict as
well her drug is uh crack yeah crack
okay what is your drug mine is crack
cocaine as well and
fenol
yeah I actually use both at the same
time like what a crack pipe I put fenol
in yeah so like that's how a lot of the
deps have been happening people have
been picking up pipes that have fenol in
them and kind of like makes me a
liability around here because if I knot
off and a pipe drops and some smoker
comes up and picks it up and takes a hit
they're thinking that there's only crack
cocaine in there but there's fentanyl as
well there's fenyl in there and they
look similar and then and they they will
die we had quite a few um people that
was kind of the case over there on
Crocker has been already like five
deaths in the last two months of like my
close friends and at least two of them
had to do with Mod pipe I think that's
one of the most common ways that people
OD is SM they think they're smoking
crack and it's rarely not even like on
purpose like somebody's like put it on
it's it's so like freak accident like
it's like there's no intention none of
that you know and you just kind of gota
gotta go to bed every day and just you
know live with that so so J wants to
keep the child yeah she does and it
makes me happy cuz she doesn't really
have a lot to live for her yeah but she
is using yeah and it's not very likely
and yeah that's that she'll keep the
baby if she still got drugs in her
system yeah that's what's kind of making
me like stressed out every day you know
but all I could do is just be there for
her you know through it all how are you
guys making money um well she's
prostituting and um when she can't pick
up you know dates and something like
that there'll be men that you know like
men too like homosexuals and I'll I'll
volunteer myself to go and make money
with them as well you know they asked me
to do a lot of weird stuff but in the
back of my head I'm thinking okay well
the money is going to go for her to
eat and you know that's what matters is
long as she has food in her stomach and
that's the only way I know how to you
know provide for her right now because
she's hungry she's gaining weight she
man she she's
heavy you're not gay or by no I'm not so
that that's yeah it's kind of like shows
your dedication
to really new for me and it's like
sometimes like when they ask me to do
stuff I'm just like so like disgusted
with myself and so like like all my
pride is just and when I go back with
the money she smiles and like you know
she's happy but deep down I'm broken
inside like cuz I lost like my manhood
basically this kid really such a tough
life for for men and women yeah everyone
thinks like oh it's easy it's easy for
girls I can just get money and do most
of them don't even want to do the stuff
that they're asking them so it's not
easy and it's not easy for men either
because if you have a good-looking face
or a good-look body and you're just
attracted
person you're you're you're obviously
like prey towards these men that are
just you know got so much power over
everyone because of the drug oh I can
have this person do whatever they want
because they're a f and they're on drugs
so I'm going to hold this drug until
they do what I want and more than likely
the person is going to give in because
they don't want to be sick or they have
something to provide for you know like a
family and something like
that so I mean I just try to forget
about it and I'll and I'll talk to her
about the things that you know I do so I
could be honest with her and she's not
really too happy about it but then again
I'm not happy about the things that she
has to do as well so we're kind of just
having to just wash all that off and
just forget about it and start a new day
I think your story is
a much more common story than we we know
because I think a lot of guys just don't
want to admit what yeah a lot of people
are just like uh I just want to do it on
the low and they actually like it and
stuff like that like I've I've cried
plenty of times during these situations
and it's crazy how somebody could just
not have a heart to just like keep doing
and torturing
somebody when they know that they're
just doing it to support
something
do you feel like given the childhood
that you had living a life you know kind
of like you are is is was almost like in
the cards for you um not really I mean I
had a great I had a golden spoonfed life
so I'm not used to none of this and now
that it's all going bad it's kind of
like didn't you tell me your mom was out
here yeah my mom she actually relapsed
came back to the streets was living out
here with me and my girlfriend for a
year and she went and got clean again
she recently just got off the streets so
it's kind of like but your childhood was
was pretty smooth it it was only because
my mom gave me up to the system and oh
and the family they raised yeah so gave
me a better life but soon as like my got
out of high school it was just like okay
now what do I do now you know and it was
just like foster parents were just like
you know don't let the door hit you on
the way out you know we don't got to
take care of you no more we already
collected your checks you know just is
that's just crazy how people could just
do that how old are you now I'm 21 years
old 21 yeah I've been out here since 18
and you you reconnected with your mom
what was that like um honestly it was it
was it was a good you know year that I
had with her because when she's sober
and I'm out here we don't talk at all
like to this day we won't talk but when
she's out here doing drugs with me oh
like peas in a
pot like man I just never had that with
relationship towards my mom so I didn't
care if people were like oh that's bad
your Mom's letting you do drugs in front
of her you guys are smoking together
that's not a mom I never had a mom I
never you know we never talked like that
we never were that close so to have
something to relate to regardless if it
was something bad it was it was fun for
me you know I just got to laugh with her
you know take care of her you know
hustle for her whatever you know [__] I
didn't get as a
kid what's your what's your biggest fear
now the biggest fear
um losing my my woman just to the
streets you know like there's so many
stories of like girls just doing this
one drug and they just go berserk like
they're just lost in all that I don't
want nothing to happen to her mentally
and you know it's already it's already
tough enough to just see like the
bruises and the cuts and the stars and
just having to remember room you know
like I'll just check her body every day
and I'm like what's this from like
what's this bruis from what's this cut
from and she'll be scared to tell me
like who hit
you and you know like just I'm the same
way though like when she sees this on my
face and she's like what happened and
like you know like I'm afraid to tell
her stuff you know because I don't want
her to leave me and I'm pretty sure she
feels the same way she she has to lie to
me a lot just so I can control my anger
cuz she knows that I'll end up in jail
if she told me what really wouldn't
happen and all
that it's kind of like she gets mad at
me too like for for prostituting myself
CU she doesn't think that she really
believes that I'm gay now like she
thinks that I'm into this stuff and
she's starting to like back up for me
like oh my man's not the same person
like he's not a man no
more
it's just hard to explain to her you
know that it's for money you know
and I just keep it away from her you
know I don't tell her that I I do that
on the side but she'll she'll Wonder
like why is he walking away right now
how come he doesn't tell me nothing how
come he's just leaving with some dude
how come he's always hanging out with
his homeboy so much how come he's
hanging out with this older man so
much and then I come back hours later
happy as a [__] bread in my hand
money like here baby what you need what
you need what you need that makes me
feel good but then she questions where'd
you get this you know like she's I
haven't went to work I haven't went did
anything with no men yet how you got
money you went to go steal from a store
yeah I went to go steal from a
store that's my story how much do you
get for a date with a guy um it's not
much man it's probably like 50 to 80
bucks the max it's only because I'm not
doing nothing from my rear end you know
I'm just either having to do oral or
giving them a hand job [__] like
that yeah that's got to be rough yeah
it's it's disgusting man for
me do you have any goals anything you'd
like to do with your life yeah soon as
soon as this um proceeds you know like
my goal is one to just get her off
smoking I I want to get myself clean too
because it's not fair for her to get off
and me to just be doing it on the low
and [__] so probably this month's going
to be a rough month for us having to
slow down you know we're not going to do
a cold turkey I'm going to have to ease
off for both of us little by little and
um I want to get a job regardless if I
don't stop smoking or whatever I'm going
to get a job cuz this can last forever I
can't keep doing this for my kid and my
goal is to make that baby come
out and have my first child and give it
the life I didn't get yeah you guys are
gonna have to make some hard decisions
yeah especially her she's she can't move
nowhere she can't walk nowhere I'd be
mad at her like come on let's go we got
to go hustle we got to go make some
money we're not going to just sit around
here laying dead like with flies and
[__] dirt and trash around us like
let's go make some money for a
hotel she can't move she can't get up
you guys are stay in a tent yeah and I
and I don't realize I don't put myself
in her position like okay she's walking
down the block and going uh I'm
like I shouldn't be getting mad at her
like she's she's carrying something that
I don't know how that feels so I gotta
just ease up on her you know I'm just
expecting so much from her but I don't I
don't know what it is to carry you know
another person in you so she's tired a
lot she goes to sleep a lot of the
time and um yeah I got she in the middle
of the night she'll end up just crapping
on herself I got to wipe her you know
like just do [__] that I never thought I
would do for somebody but um it just
shows how much love and dedication I
have for
her she doesn't really see
it because all she focuses on is well
you're going out and doing this and that
but
like overall the bigger picture is I'm
sure it's trying to be an allaround guy
for her you know just provide everything
for
her no matter what it
takes if I loser I lose
myself all right angel thank you so much
for sharing your story all right I wish
you guys all the luck in the world
you're going to need it yeah
thanks